cuz some people
think that this makes will look good
like if F like we have sympathy for him
that he'll be able to come back I don't
think so to me this makes it look worse
because of ass SLA cuz now I don't know
what was going on that night I don't
know what that was about now you know
and all the people who were like oh
comedians in their jokes it wasn't about
that at all you look so dumb right now
if you were one of those idiots who were
like well you know you talk about
somebody's wife or you know when you do
jokes comedians are out of pocket that I
maintain what I said last year that was
a nothing joke a dad joke oh see you and
GI Jane that was nothing this is so much
more deep it has everything to do with
this fraud of a couple